My AST and ALT have improved since going off bed. Alpha alkaline phosphatase is still high.
I've started having acid reflux or acid indigestion. Could they be related or are they separate?
Is acid reflex related to elevated alkaline phosphatase? No, I don't think so.
So, the way you would differential diagnose whether by elevated ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase is coming
from, what is that coming from? So, you kind of go through this process of, well, if the ALT and AST
are going to be elevated if there's irritation to the liver, alkaline phosphatase can be also elevated
if there's irritation to the liver. But with the person with a diagnosis of cancer, alkaline phosphatase
can also be elevated if they have metastasis. So, alkaline phosphatase is elevated if there's irritation
to the liver, or there's tissue damage somewhere else. Most commonly, tissue damage to the bone.
So, if I have metastasis to the bone by alkaline phosphatase is going to go up.
Many times it will follow, be followed by calcium being elevated as well because the irritation,
the destruction of the bone is going to elevate calcium levels. So, that's how you'd kind of walk
through that differential diagnosis. I have AST elevated, ALT elevated, alkaline phosphatase elevated,
well, let's say calcium is normal, then I go off a fed bed, my AST at ALT go down, but my alkaline
phosphatase stays up. I'd want to say, okay, where's my calcium at? Well, my calcium is still higher
than normal. Well, do I know have no metastasis somewhere? I would want to be looking for that.
Because the wall alkaline phosphatase can go up with a drug irritation like fed bed is all.
If it stays elevated the other two go down, I'd go, huh, do I have no metastasis? Is there growth
and destruction somewhere else? That's what I don't want to look at. Could that be related to
a heavy acid reflux or acid in digestion? I would say no, probably not. You could say, well,
what if the first day has metastasis to the stomach? Well, metastasis to the stomach is quite rare,
so I wouldn't even think that. Acid reflux and indigestion are going to be obviously quite
common. It's probably most common symptom. There is non-cancer patients, and it's always tied to
NHCL deficiency. So go back to my blog and look at the hypochloridria blog posts. Think about
starting with the apple cider vinegar or something like that to call the stomach. Maybe get it on
GI soothes to help heal the stomach. That's one of the things I would first think about.
So that's kind of my thoughts in there.